deep in tropical jungles lie floating
kingdoms ruled by beautiful and deadly
masters
they're sort of the high elves of the
ant kingdoms talented architects that
create castles and city-states
but they are also fierce and
expansionist warriors and their kingdoms
are ensnared in a never-ending war for
survival
oecoffla weaver ants
[Music]
oecoflu weavers walk on long legs have
slender bodies and large eyes which make
them look pretty cute
although their strong mandibles and the
ability to shoot acid also make them
pretty good at killing
but more on that later
their colonies usually have two to three
worker classes that vary dramatically in
size
majors miners and sometimes even tiny
minim workers
depending on location and species they
vary in color from dark brown to emerald
green
other than their fancy looks what makes
weavers special is that they're in the
kingdom building business
they like to build at pretty much all
heights starting in shrubs a few
centimeters above the ground and up to
10 meters in the tree canopy
but they're not satisfied with ruling
just one plant
weavers will look for twigs or lianas
that bridge the gap to other trees and
expand to every plant they can reach
this way colonies spread upwards and
sideways through the treetops
the largest weaver ant kingdoms we know
of occupy up to 1
600 square meters around 4 basketball
courts
a lot of ground to cover for tiny ants
and impossibly hard to control
so weaver ants construct dozens of nests
scattered all over their territory
outposts to defend the kingdom
tubes or balls made from leaves and
ghostly silk sheets
these masterpieces of high-end
architecture are created by the weaver
magers the larger worker ants which are
responsible for the more dangerous jobs
like fighting foraging and nest
construction
to start a new nest a major tries to
bend different leaves in her
surroundings into a tube if one of the
leaves is flexible enough more workers
will arrive to help
chains of workers pull the leaf's edges
together or reach across gaps and grab
distant leaves to add them to the
construction
while the bending and pulling is going
on other workers carry larvae from the
closest nest to the construction site
usually ant larvae spin themselves a
cocoon to protect themselves but the
weaver and larvae give all of their silk
to the colony as building material
so when the workers tap the larvae's
heads on the leaf they release their
sticky thread like tiny cute glue guns
this way the workers sew the bent leaf
onto itself so it won't unfold anymore
this creates a central chamber that's
used as the basis for up to 300 more
leaves that are wound around it
together they form little pockets and
act as additional rooms for the new
outpost
to make it even more cozy miner workers
use the larvae to weave additional
floors and chambers
nests are usually constructed as
barracks on the territories borders or
as storage for brood and food supplies
this way the ants don't need to cross
vast distances to the headquarters but
have soldiers close to any potential
point of conflict
apart from one special nest in the
middle of the network which is reserved
for the queen and her guards
here she produces hundreds of eggs a day
which get transferred to suitable nests
with brood chambers
so a colony is a network of little
castles and moats connected by
suspension bridges made from leaves
lyannas and twigs
an established colony easily has half a
million individuals that need to be fed
fortunately weaver ants evolve to have
very close and beneficial relationships
with their hosts shrubs and trees
the tree gives the ants a home and
access to sweet sap to drink but maybe
even more importantly it allows them to
cultivate cattle like aphids or
caterpillars that produce honeydew for
them
this would usually hurt a tree but these
insects belong to a small group of vips
only a few selected neighbors and the
ants cattle are allowed on the fruit
tree many other insects and even larger
herbivores are scared off or even killed
and eaten
so in most cases the tree only has to
tolerate acceptable levels of damage
while being protected from more
dangerous pests
the weaver ant kingdom could be an ant
paradise if there wasn't competition
mostly from other kingdoms just like
medieval humans every queen seeks to
conquer others and make their land their
own
controlling fertile land is the key to
survive in the jungle
and if a kingdom loses too much of it it
shrinks and is overrun or starves to
death
so expanding and defending their borders
is critical to keep the colony alive
when a kingdom invades another it first
gathers an army of a few thousand majors
who make their way towards the opposing
colony
the goal is to steal a bit of territory
and take it over
defending weaver patrols quickly spot
the invaders and immediately release an
alarm pheromone
some rush to the front to defend while
others rush to the closest outposts for
help marking their route with pheromones
whenever they meet other sisters they
jerk their bodies as if in a fight to
signal them to follow the pheromone
trail to the front line
at the site of battle mages from both
parties raise their bodies circle each
other with mandibles wide open and try
to seize their opponents
if an ant gets a hold of her opponent
the victim is pulled into a group of
allied mages and pinned down
the ants then ripped the victim apart
clipping off antennae and legs and
slicing open their abdomens
to slow down the advance of the
attackers the defending mages squirt
formic acid over the battlefield to
chemically burn their targets
this is soon answered in the same way by
the attackers
in the chaotic battle both parties lose
countless fighters on the increasingly
acidic battlefield
after a few minutes the backup from the
outposts arrive and the time window for
a successful attack slowly closes
this is when the battle turns
the defenders slowly push back the
attack party
in the end the attackers can't keep up
and have to retreat
for both parties it was a costly battle
thousands of corpses lie piled up on the
ground under the battlefield and many
ants are severely injured
the defending colonies nests and brood
are safe though
the attackers attempt to steal new
valuable territory has failed for today
they'll try again soon
but the kingdom will be ready
for the high ants of the floating
kingdoms war is nothing special it's
just a fact of life
because as we know empires never ever
have enough
and the weaver ants are ready to fight
this video is part three in a series
that was developed with the support of
curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service with thousands of
documentaries and non-fiction titles
curiosity stream was founded by the same
people who started the discovery channel
so it's all about documentaries on
science nature history technology and
pretty much any other topic of interest
you can think of
if you're the same as us and love to
learn things while watching fun videos
this is for you for example david
attenborough's and mountain the perfect
sequel to this video to let you stay in
the ant realm for a little longer you
can watch thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction tv shows on all streaming
devices for only 2.99 per month
and there's a special treat for
kurtzgazzant viewers
by clicking the link in the inbox and
using the code kutzgazant you get 25 off
your annual plan
that means it's just 14.99
for the entire year
thanks to our friends at curiositystream
for supporting us in making ambitious
and beautiful projects like this video
happen stay antsy for part four and
visit
to curiositystream.com your discount
thank you for watching
[Music]
you